peut-être que la première chose qui
viendra l'esprit c'est l'ancrage
l'ancrage
pour avoir des enseignements par exemple
un arbre si tu regardes les racines plus
elles sont profondes puis ça son solide
et finalement tu peux imaginer le
feuillage d'accord et ben plus on est
ancré en tant qu'être humain plus on
arrive à centrer dans le moment présent
et naturellement on a cette connexion
aussi avec ce que moi j'appelle voilà la
source tu vois le divin ou peu importe
et qui te donne en fait finalement cette
des émotions de gratitude de de de
reconnaissance de joie de joie de vivre
et beaucoup de force vitale et
finalement je me suis rendu compte que
plus je devais heureuse et naturellement
finalement les les facultés
extrasensorielles aussi vont avec on a
plus d'intuition on développe presque
des antennes bienveillantes comme si on
sentait quand une personne va pas bien
donc finalement l'ancrage c'est quoi le
moment présent c'est tout simplement
c'est être là est-ce que tu m'écoutes
par exemple pendant que je parle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la cuisine et on pense à autre chose
alors qu'on n'est pas là en train de
regarder sa couleur de le sentier de
couper vraiment en disant j'aimerais
jouir parce que j'ai partagé ce bon
repas avec du monde finalement plus on
est dans ce moment-là
elle a raison pour la santé là il y a eu
des dernières études comme quoi
lorsqu'on est dans la joie la gratitude
lorsque voilà ça développe les la force
vitale les défenses féminines
immunitaires c'est et c'est toute la
sagesse ancestrale qui nous l'avait déjà
communiqué est-ce que Cyril vous le
sentez ancrée ancré dans le canapé
[Applaudissements]
sans avoir quand même un certain ancrage
c'est-à-dire que je pense que c'est
quelqu'un oui il est je pense que vous
n'êtes pas beaucoup dans dans les
émotions vous n'êtes pas beaucoup dans
le haut vous êtes bien dans la terre
derrière ça se voit dans votre démarche
on voit bien que vous êtes dans le bar
alors du coup
on peut avoir tendance à couper la
spiritualité
aussi bien moi je te connaissais tu as
toujours eu un carrément c'est une
grande générosité donc ça ça tu l'as
toujours la seule chose c'est que c'est
vrai que et je te l'ai dit en loge tout
à l'heure est-ce que tu pries un peu
parce que ça aussi c'est une deuxième
clé alors ça dépasse religieuse la
prière parce que finalement elle peut
être laïque les enfants instinctivement
il joignent les mains quand ils veulent
qu'un désir
quand elle veut que tu achètes un truc
c'est un désir c'est souhaiter
parce que la conscience que la matière
la conscience crée l'expérience de vie
et naturellement sans le savoir
il joigne les mains et en fait l'énergie
dans la médecine chinoise toute
l'énergie du corps passe dans les mains
pour cette haute concentration donc en
fait voilà désirez souhaiter et je pense
que souhaiter des des
justement ça aussi c'est génial c'est
plus on devient heureux et puis ça
devient un acte vraiment divin
puisqu'on est dans votre
castor
on se rejoint dans tous les corps dans
toutes les dimensions
donc finalement là c'est une communion
on est vraiment avec la personne on est
connaissance parce qu'on les a
développés donc finalement et d'ailleurs
le kamasutra qui vient de de voilà de
l'Inde de là où je viens aussi et on me
l'avait offert quand j'avais 15 ans et
c'est vrai qu'au-delà finalement de tous
ces chiffres
[Rires]
qui développe aussi tous les
sensations
en fait finalement tout est beau mais
les spirituels sont souvent très très
porté sur la chose
Raymond lété il chante et il dit le
Kâmasûtra c'est un peu c'est un peu bon
c'est un peu mon Naya kamasutra
place que j'ai dans mon cerveau vous
avez tous cas là dans la tête la place
dans ton slip aussi
Karine en tout cas on adore écouter
c'est vrai que on ça nous fait réfléchir
après je sais pas quoi mais voilà non
mais c'est vrai
lui prie pour trouver 500000 €
Benjamin tu pries pour avoir 500000 €.
mais que
le résultat va être beaucoup plus
accéléré si c'est basé sur le grand ego
le carrelage c'est à dire que finalement
500000 euros mais qu'avec ça tu vas
t'acheter une voiture mais tu vas aussi
inviter des gens dans cette voiture vous
allez créer des valeurs ensemble
dans une vibration qui qui est lumineuse
moi j'ai une question est-ce que vous
croyez au karma est-ce que si on fait le
prix pendant plusieurs années nous
arrivent du mal alors
non mais c'est très intéressant le karma
parce que on connaît tous un petit peu
les
la définition du karma c'est un peu
cette tirelire plus ou moins implique
quand on arrive dans cette vie signe et
ce serait toutes les causes que l'on a
créé depuis le passé infiniment lointain
et d'ailleurs il y a une fraise qui dit
si tu veux comprendre ton présent essaie
d'observer un petit peu les causes que
tu as planté dans cette vie si dans le
passé
comprendre ou savoir un peu ce qui va se
passer dans le futur regarde les causes
que tu plantes dans ton présent alors
c'est quoi les causes c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est les pensées
les actions et les paroles mais après on
n'est pas des soldats moi j'aime le
processus naturel des choses c'est à
dire que c'est plutôt comment moi je
fais vivre ma vie quand moi je deviens
plus heureuse pour que naturellement
découle des paroles des actes et
finalement des actions qui sont beaucoup
plus lumineuses et qui créent
après le karma pour moi c'est le bon
karma parfois c'est aussi d'avoir des
difficultés moi aujourd'hui ça a été les
plus beaux cadeaux tout ce que j'ai vécu
ces moments difficiles dans ma vie mon
permis de peut-être gagner un petit peu
en sagesse en profondeur en
reconnaissance en humilité aussi et je
dirais même que le karma s'appelait
encore plus loin c'est à dire qu'on
pourrait envisager le karma en se disant
voilà comme trois personnes qui
regarderaient un coucher de soleil le
soir la première est tellement affairée
à ses affaires que finalement elle voit
même plus le coucher de soleil la
deuxième elle le voit tellement tous les
soirs que maintenant elle le voit elle
le voit même plus et puis la troisième
elle passe depuis des années devant le
même que j'ai de soleil et elle est
toujours émerveillée et finalement quel
est le regard que l'on pose sur les
choses et c'est ça le bon karma pour moi
ça répare ça remplace du coup est-ce que
ça fonctionne par exemple quand
Guillaume à chaque fois qu'il voit un QI
c'est merveille ça fonctionne
[Rires]
des bons sentiments et que c'est en
respectant la personne en face
exactement ça fait plaisir Géraldine
parce que je pensais pas avoir un tel
accueil pourquoi ben parce que vous êtes
plutôt
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais vous savez que la science trouve
aussi et ce qui est merveilleux parce
que vous qui aimez la science même c'est
important de dire ça parce que je sais
que vous aimez que tout ça pourrait par
la science mais justement le véritable
scientifique il accepte cet endroit
impalpable par exemple quand vous dites
je t'aime à votre mari vous pouvez pas
me prouver que vous l'aimez absolument
c'est l'indicible c'est à dire que en
fait vous pouvez me dire mais si je lui
dis tous les soirs je t'aime et je lui
donne des cadeaux etc c'est quelque
chose d'invisible et c'est la libération
du cœur il y a que la personne en face
de vous
[Rires]
faire du bien tu vois pas la vibration
du cœur
tu le vois pas ça
c'est que la vie n'est pas punition ou
récompense de vie soit évolutive ou soit
agressifs on a le libre arbitre en
revanche je pense que c'est pas des
punitions lorsqu'on est des obstacles
c'est juste que c'est l'effet de j'ai
planté des causes j'ai un résultat mais
qui me permet finalement de retrouver
cette lumière finalement c'est c'est
comme des occasions merveilleuses
qui ont vécu des difficultés sont les
chercher le divin en soi
[Rires]
je me suis endormie au bout de 5 minutes